todo comenzó un día que fue una noche
era el mediodía de 1991 yo tenía 5 años
y lloraba desconsolada
una hora antes mi madre había sido
llamada por parte de la psicóloga de la
escuela donde yo estudiaba
y de alguna forma me percaté que mi
madre estaba triste
tenía furia
la psicóloga le había citado en esta
ocasión para mencionarle que yo era una
niña con muchos problemas y que no iba a
terminar mi educación básica
en esta ocasión regresa vamos a nuestra
casa me acuerdo perfectamente que yo iba
sentada atrás en el coche en mi mente de
niña no encontraba la manera en cómo
explicar este silencio por parte de mi
madre y de alguna forma el entender este
fenómeno natural y el contexto escolar
en el que yo me encontraba
un recorrido silencioso fuera de lo
común porque normalmente en mi mamá lo
que hacía era poner música y
regresábamos a casa cantando esta
ocasión era totalmente distinto recuerdo
perfectamente que llegamos al primer
alto y mi madre me volteó y me dijo
hija tienes que hacer fuerte muchas
veces no es bueno mostrarse débil ante
la gente seguimos hacia la casa y al
siguiente alto mi madre volvió a voltear
y me dijo ra que tú eres una niña muy
inteligente todo mundo es capaz de hacer
lo que quiera que nadie venga y te
limite nunca
hola buenas noches mi nombre es raquel
león y podrían contarles muchísimas
historias que tienen que ver con
violencia más como mujer con mi
condición de mujer por ejemplo las dos
veces que sufrí un intento de violación
durante mi vida universitaria o tal vez
a lo mejor la violencia psicológica por
parte de ex parejas o incluso mi
condición de mujer y extranjera como un
elemento de discriminación en otros
países o peor aún sufrir acoso laboral
por parte de uno de mis colegas sin
embargo creo que todos los que estamos
aquí sin importar sexo o género en algún
momento hemos sufrido de violencia
esta situación no quiere decir que la
normalicemos sino que creo que esta
charla va más en un sentido de poder
darle la vuelta a esta cara de la moneda
y entender que por este mundo podemos
hacer cosas mejores
rescatando esto y como apasionada de los
estudios de china me encanta pensar que
la educación nos lleva a la virtualidad
y es entonces que la plática que vengo a
mencionarles el día de hoy tiene que ver
con cuatro historias que parten de
cuatro grandes maestros con cuatro
enseñanzas que me han servido para
construir me y al mismo tiempo de
construir me como mujer
mi primera maestra mi madre
mi primer referente como mujer es a ese
mediodía que parecía noche me dio mi
primera lección en este caso entender
que en cada uno de nosotros no existe
una fortaleza que es tan grande y que
nos tiene que llevar en algún momento a
correlacionar nos con todas las personas
que existimos
según los datos del gobierno de eeuu
estamos cercanos a llegar a casi 7.500
millones de habitantes en este planeta
se imaginan qué pasaría si juntáramos la
fortaleza de todos los seres vivos que
coexistimos en este planeta con un solo
fin el bienestar no sé ustedes pero para
mí creo que sería algo excepcional
una segunda lección que dio mi madre a
mí fue la siguiente
raquel cuando hagas algo hazlo bien sino
no hagas nada
aquí entré en una pregunta creo que
existencial para todos que nos lleva a
lo largo de nuestras vidas a
preguntarnos qué es hacer bien las cosas
de alguna forma mi segundo maestro mi
padre me llevó a tener ciertas pistas
con respecto a saber qué es hacer bien
las cosas
y esto tiene que ver con algo que
pareciera ser tiene este momento escucho
a mi padre decirme al oído raquel ponte
en los zapatos de los demás alguna vez
se han puesto en los zapatos de los
demás
cuántas veces has ido
los invito a que cerremos los ojos
cerramos los ojos todos
y piensa
cuántas veces te has puesto en los
zapatos de los demás
inhala
exhala
y deja salir con ese aliento las cosas
que hiciste o dejaste de hacer por
alguien más
abre tus ojos
cuando nos ponemos en los zapatos de los
demás creamos varias cosas primero
conectamos en un segundo momento
sentimos en un tercer momento creamos
empatía conocemos y entendemos
pero lo más importante
que cuando nos ponemos en los zapatos de
los demás podemos ser podemos ser
humanos
estas dos lecciones me llevan a entender
que de alguna forma existen ciertos
pensamientos importantes que me han
marcado uno de ellos parte del
pensamiento confusión o confusión decía
leer un libro sin saberlo es ignorante
pensar sin leer causará muchas dudas o
en palabras más coloquiales porque lo
intenté traducir del chino dice el
conocimiento sin reflexión es inútil la
reflexión sin conocimiento es peligrosa
de alguna forma esta frase enfrasca dos
cosas que me apasionan mucho primero
china y en un segundo momento el
conocimiento y me lleva a poder analizar
un poco tanto como conocí a mi tercer
maestro de alguna forma como buen
psicólogo es importante adentrarte en el
idioma que creo que ha sido una aventura
que no he podido concretar al 100% y es
de alguna forma así como conocí a wisin
using una china nacida por ahí de la
década de los 70s en una comunidad al
sur de china llamada nanín
era una mujer o ha sido una mujer sin
precedente dentro de su historia y de su
comunidad desde muy chica
por sus características físicas fue
invitada a tomar una beca y salir de su
casa para formarse como gimnasta y
artista de alguna forma esta situación
también la llevó a ir más allá de la
muralla china y comenzar a viajar por el
mundo y como pueblo en plena era de la
globalización' no era la excepción con
esta tendencia de que todo el mundo
queríamos saber que era china y aprender
chino mandarín
fue así como llevó a puebla y se hizo
profesora en una universidad
yo de alguna manera me escribió uno de
estos cursos y más allá de la aventura
que me significaba poder aprender a
pronunciar una palabra en chino
básicamente desde el mi hija o de alguna
forma lo que más recuerdo de kutxi fue
unas palabras que me dijo mientras
comíamos en un buffet aquí en puebla me
dijo raquel yo soy como un globo mis
padres me inflaron cuando era yo niña y
es a partir de entonces que comencé a
viajar por todo el mundo y hasta que ese
aire salga de ese globo dejaré yo de
existir y de viajar
esta enseñanza de alguna forma me marcó
de manera definitiva para mis 25 años
quise romper ciertos estereotipos y
dejar de depender de que una joya o un
anillo de compromiso fuera lo que
determinará mi conexión con el corazón
decidí que mi corazón se tenía que
conectar con el mundo y fue entonces
cuando decidí vender ese anillo
y viajar por todo el mundo y comencé a
viajar por mí misma que era lo más
importante quitar misterios estereotipos
conocer culturas de alguna manera
entender al que estaba frente a mí
comprender la otredad y sobre todo
comprenderme a mí misma fuera de un
contexto básico
de alguna forma el tema del proceso en
el que uno encuentra vocaciones no es
fácil debe uno estar pasando por ciertos
procesos y esto me lleva a mi cuarto
maestro tiene que ver en este caso con
misa el misael fue profesor mío durante
la universidad y fue la primera persona
que creyó en mí para dedicarme a hacer
lo que más amo en esta vida que es ser
profesora e investigadora
para algunos estudios dentro de la
sociología como es el caso de nicholas
christakis y el caso de james fowler
dicen en su libro conectados que las
redes sociales tienen una belleza
intrincada
dicen ellos en las primeras líneas de
este libro que de alguna forma
estas dos personas pueden comenzar a
hacer un contacto sin embargo e ir más
allá de nos podríamos identificar redes
tan complejas que podrían cubrir todo el
mundo de alguna manera a mí después de
esta de esta reflexión misael me dijo lo
siguiente
reich
mi plan de retiro es poder
pisar cualquier parte del mundo y tener
a un exalumno para poder platicar
tomarme un café o de alguna forma poder
de alguna manera convivir y ver cómo han
mejorado no se trata de comerte todo el
pastel se trata de hacerlo más grande a
partir de entonces esto cambió mi vida y
el tema de cómo quería yo ser vista como
profesora creando verdaderas redes no
las sociales que quedan en un estatus
frío sino realmente a partir de la
educación crear redes a través de formar
agentes de cambio de gente con pasión
por la vida con gente que quiera mejorar
y darle valor a este mundo
mi nombre es aquel león
este es mi red a través de la educación
los invito a que nos conectemos gracias
[Aplausos]